good morning
i have some great pleasure and honor to
welcome
dr ozola fond alliance president
of the
european commission
to be with us
and actually
madam president
you
opened our 50th anniversary and many of
the people will still remember what
a wonderful location it has been
and you just had assumed the presidency
i think two months earlier
and now we are back
26 months later 28 months later
how the world has changed
and you have been at the central point
of all those changes
actually
having to support the burden of those
changes and to make sure
that
we take the necessary reactions i mean
it's just unbelievable
you you started your your mandate
with the commitment to make europe
more digital to make it
grino
and i think you have made great progress
in this respect but son covet came and
you
took a major role
in terms of vaccines
we had to manage the consequences of
koid
just imagine what it means to put
together a 800 billion recovery
programme
and then
just three months ago
the
war
the aggression of russia on ukraine
happened
and you took again a very determining
all
in
in shaping
europe's reaction
if i would summarize
europe is back
and so forth
we have the great pleasure to welcome
you here
please greet the president of the
european
commission
rossella van der luyk
[Applause]
thank you very much klaus
ladies and gentlemen
indeed
following your introduction dear claus
it is difficult to believe
that in davos today
we're talking about war
because
the divorce spirit
is the anti-thesis
of war
it is about forging ties
and together finding solutions for the
big challenges of the
world you might remember
and you worked on it together with us
that in recent years
we have looked at smart and sustainable
ways
to fight climate change
and how to shape globalization so that
all can benefit
how to make digitalization a force for
good
and mitigate its risks for democracies
so davos is all about crafting a better
future together
that is what we should be talking here
about today
but instead
we must address the cost
and consequences
of putin's war of choice
the playbook
of russia's aggression against ukraine
comes straight out of another century
treating millions of people
not as human beings
but as faceless populations to be moved
or controlled
or set as a buffer
between military forces
trying to trample the aspiration
of an
entire nation
with tanks
this is not just a matter of ukraine
survival
this is not just an issue of european
security
this is putting our whole international
order into question
and that's why countering russia's
aggression
is a task for the entire
global community
ukraine must win this war
and putin's aggression
must be a strategic failure
so we will do everything we can
to help ukrainians prevail and retake
the future into their hands
for the first time in history
the european union is providing military
aid to country under attack
we are mobilizing our full economic
power
our sanctions
and the self sanctionings of companies
themselves
are draining russia's
economy and thus draining the kremlin's
war machine
our member states are caring for six
million ukrainian refugees
and actually there are eight million
internally displaced people in ukraine
itself
and in parallel
ukraine needs direct budget support now
to keep the economy running it's about
pensions it's about salaries
it's about the basic services that have
to be provided
and therefore
we have proposed a 10 billion euros
macro financial assistance
it is the largest package of macro
financial assistance ever conceived by
the european union for a third country
other countries starting with our
friends in the united states
are doing their utmost too
it is an economic relief operation with
no precedent
in recent history
but that is the short term
and much more needs to be done
so with the same result
we will hand in hand
help ukraine
rise from the ashes
that's the idea behind the
reconstruction platform
that i proposed to president zielinski
you remember that yesterday
in his speech here in davos
he recognized the unprecedented
unity of the democratic world
the understanding
that freedom must be fought for
so the rebuilding of ukraine
also calls for an unprecedented unity
as president zielinski said
the work that has to be done is colossal
but together
we can
and we will master the challenge
and that is why i have proposed this
reconstruction platform
to be led by ukraine
and the european commission
because we will combine
reform
with investment
the platform invites global
contributions
from any country that cares about the
future of ukraine
from international financial
institutions
from the private sector we need everyone
on board
and i was very glad
to hear about the lugano initiative
yesterday
called it a martial plan for ukraine
and ladies and gentlemen
we should leave no stone unturned
that is including if possible the
russian assets that we have frozen
but this is not only about undoing the
damage of putin's
destructive
fury it is also about building the
future that ukrainians have chosen
themselves
for years now the people of ukraine have
worked for change
and that is why they elected volodomia
zelensky in the first place
the reconstruction of the country
should combine massive investment
with ambitious reforms
for example to modernize ukraine's
administrative capacity
to firmly establish
the rule of law
and the independence of the judiciary
to fight corruption get rid of the
oligarchs
to build a fair sustainable and strong
competitive economy
and thus
to firmly support ukraine in pursuing
its european path
ukraine belongs into the european family
ukrainians have stood tall in the face
of brutal violence they have stood for
their own freedom
but also for our values and for humanity
so we stand with them
and i think
this is a defining moment for all
democracies on the whole globe
ladies and gentlemen
this conflict is also sending shockwaves
throughout the world further disrupting
supply chains
already stretched by the pandemic
it is putting new burdens on businesses
and households
and it has created a thick fog of
uncertainty for investors across the
globe
and more and more companies and
countries already battered by two years
of covet 19
and all the resulting supply chain
issues
must now cope
with rising price energy prices for
energy
as a direct result
of putin's unpardonable war
and russia has tried
to put pressure on us
for example by cutting the energy
supplies the gas supplies
of bulgaria
poland and now lately finland
but this world
and this behavior we see
has only strengthened europe's resolve
to get rid of russian fossil fuel
dependency
rapidly
the climate cannot wait
but now
the geopolitical reasons are evident too
we have to diversify away from fossil
fuels
we have set our course already towards
climate neutrality
so now we must accelerate our clean
energy transition and fortunately
we are already having in place
the means
to do so
the european green deal is already
ambitious
but now we are taking our ambition yet
to another level
last week
the european commission
tabled and proposed
re-power issue
that is our 300 billion euro plan
to phase out of fossil for russian
fossil fuels and fast forward the green
transition
and today
if we look at the share of renewables we
have in europe
almost a quarter of the energy we
consume in europe
stems from renewable sources already
this is the famous european green deal
but now through we power eu
we will practically double
this share
to 45
in 2013
this is only possible
by also bringing
cross-border cooperation to a new level
take for example
the
north sea of europe and what is
happening there
last week we had four european member
states joining forces
to harness
the energy of offshore wind
and they decided
to quadruple their offshore wind
capacity by 2030.
that will mean
wind farms in the north sea
will cover the annual energy consumption
of more than 50 million homes
this is roughly one quarter of all
european households
this is the right way to go
renewable energy is basically our
springboard
towards net zero co2 emissions
and it is good for the climate
but it is also good for our independence
and for our security of energy supply
the same is true
for the diversification of our gas
supply
this is another pillar of repower eu
as we speak europe is concluding new
arrangements
with reliable
trustworthy suppliers all over the world
in march
i agreed with president biden
to significantly step up lng deliveries
from the united states to the european
union
the amount will replace around about one
third of the russian gas we have today
more energy pipeline gas will also come
from the middle east and north africa
new lng terminals in greece and cyprus
and in poland will soon become
operational
as will new interconnectors
and important is that
the connecting pipeline infrastructure
will then over time
form the core
of our hydrogen corridors
hydrogen ladies and gentlemen
is the new frontier of europe's energy
network
but we must also think further ahead
the economies of the future will no
longer rely on oil
and coal
but on lithium for batteries
on silicon metal
for chips
on rare earth permanent magnets
for electric vehicles and wind turbines
and it's sure
the green and digital transition will
massively increase our need for these
materials
however
if we look at where we are today access
to these materials is not at all a given
for many of them
we rely on a handful of producers all
over the world
so we must avoid falling into the same
trap
as with oil and gas
we should not replace
all dependencies
with new ones
we are therefore working to ensure the
resilience of our supply chains
and again
strong international partnerships
are at the heart of the solution
so the commission has already secured
strategic raw material partnerships
with countries for example like canada
and additional reliable partnerships
will follow
once
again together we can create more
balanced interdependencies
and build supply chains
that we can really trust
ladies and gentlemen
we are witnessing
how russia is weaponizing its energy
supplies
and indeed this is having global
repercussions
unfortunately
we're seeing the same pattern
emerging in food security
ukraine is one of the world's most
fertile countries
and even its flag symbolizes the most
common ukrainian landscape
a yellow field of grain under blue blue
sky
now those fields of grain
have been scorched
in russian occupied ukraine
the kremlin's army is confiscating rain
stocks and machinery
for some this brought back memories from
a dark past the times
of the soviets
crop seizures
and the devastating famine of the 1930s
today russia's artillery is bombarding
grain war houses in ukraine
deliberately
and russia's warships
in the black sea
are blockading ukrainian ships full of
wheat and sunflower seeds
the consequences of these shameful acts
are there for everyone to see
global wheat prices are skyrocketing
and it's the fragile countries and
vulnerable populations
that suffer the most
bread prices in lebanon have increased
by 70 percent and food shipments from
odessa could not reach somalia
and on top of this russia is now
hoarding
its own food exports as a form of
blackmail
holding back
supplies to increase global prices or
trading wheat in exchange for political
support
this
is using hunger and grain
to wield power
and again
our answer is and must be
to mobilize greater collaboration and
support
at the european and global level
first europe is working hard to get
grain to global markets out of ukraine
you must know that there are currently
20 million tons of wheat stuck in
ukraine
the usual export in ukraine was 5
million tons per month
now it is down to 200 000
to 1 million
tons
by getting it out
we can provide ukrainians with the
needed revenues
and the world food program with supplies
it so badly needs
so to do this we are opening solidarity
lines
we are linking ukraine's borders to our
ports
we're financing different modes
of transportation
so that ukraine's grain can reach the
most vulnerable countries in the world
second
we're stepping up our own production
to ease pressure on global food markets
and we're working with the world food
program
so that available stocks
and additional countries
are able to reach the products to have
the products at affordable prices
global cooperation
is the antidote against russia's
blackmail third
we're supporting importing africa and
becoming less dependent on food imports
only 50 years ago
africa produced all the food it needed
for centuries
countries like egypt were the granaries
of the world
then climate change made water scarce
and the desert swallowed
hundreds of kilometers of fertile land
year after year
today
africa is heavily dependent on food
imports and this makes it vulnerable
therefore
an initiative to boost africa's own
production capacity
will be critical to strengthen
the continent's resilience
the
is
to adapt farming to a warmer and drier
age
so innovative technologies will be
crucial to leapfrog
companies around the world are already
testing high-tech solutions
for climate smart agriculture
for example precision irrigation
operating on power from renewable
or vertical farming
nanotechnologies
which can cut the use of fossil fuels
to produce fertilizers
ladies and gentlemen
the signs of a growing food crisis
are obvious
we have to act
urgently
but there are also solutions today
and on the horizon
and this is why
again
cooperation
i am working with president al-sisi
to address the repercussions of the war
with an event on food security and the
solutions coming from europe and the
region
it is time
to end the unhealthy dependencies
it is time to create new connections
it is time
to replace the old chains
with new bonds
so let's overcome these huge challenges
in cooperation and that is
in davos spirit thank you for your
attention
[Applause]
but madam president
dior
your speech i think
for me was impressive because
it was also a very
reassuring
answer to some of the concerns president
zielinski
raised yesterday so i'm very happy that
in davos
he gets also response and
second what impresses me as a
former professor for
strategy
how you take and europe takes the
existential crisis it's existential
crisis at the same
time as an opportunity
to shape its own future in a much more
constructive
way
now i have two questions two short
questions the first one is
related you you spoke about
the
strategic autonomy also in the military
sense
and we have to increase our defense
budgets but could you develop a little
bit more about it about what
the future of the european defense
mechanism could be
yes
so
first and foremost
um
it's very clear that nato is the
strongest military alliance of the world
and it will always
be
and europe will never be a military
alliance but i'm deeply convinced
that as europeans we need
to be able to care for our own defense
and to be able to be to act if being
called upon
now if you look at the last well
basically decade of defense investment
right after the financial crisis
um you see that there were enormous cut
in defense spending and if you look at
the aggregated figures now
since the financial crisis financial and
economic crisis
you see that the defense investment in
europe
rose by 20
in the united states by 65 percent
in russia by 300 percent
and in china by 600 percent
of course i know these are relative
figures but they are telling
now it is very good that
with the bitter bitter experience of war
back on european soil
we realize we have to invest much more
in a solid european defense capabilities
leaders have agreed to spend 200 billion
euros step up and spending 200 billion
euros in defense capabilities so far
this is good
very important for us in the european
union is that this is not
27 times fragmented investment in
defense capabilities because as a former
minister of defense i know very well
how important interoperability
interoperability
between armored forces is
so that you have not 17 different types
of tanks or fighter jets
but one or two
because this gives you the opportunity
to scale up
so to use the economy of scales
to
work together on spare parts but also to
exchange personnel that is trained on
that
for example an estonian pilot could fly
a fighter jet that comes from belgium
so the interoperability between the
armed forces is uh is really crucial and
therefore we are now putting up a
platform in the european union
to orchestrate and to make sure that we
have
a joint procurement approach for this
massive investment that will be there
our last
question
if you look
long term
can you ever imagine that russia
will refine its place in europe
yes it's my answer
if
russia
finds its way back
to democracy
the rule of law
the respect
for the international
rules-based order
then it's a clear yes because russia is
our neighbor russia will stay there
we share a long history
we share
culture
so
this might be and this is certainly
a
distant dream and hope
but this also says that
our
standing up against
this brutal invasion
is standing up against the leadership in
russia
it is the russian people who
are the ones
who decide about the future of their
country
they have it in their hands
and therefore
my answer is as i just said
maybe a last
very last question
of course we have we have
i mean political leaders business
leaders
[Music]
what can business leaders do if you had
a wish
really to solve support
all the program and what what should be
the mentality of the business leaders
certainly not business goes on
um we we have also to absorb what you
just told us in our mindset as business
leaders what would be your message well
um everything i've been speaking about
the knock-on effects of the war but also
that we are facing multiple prices and
the back is looming the climate crisis
and it's getting bigger and bigger
we we are still in the uh
the outgoing part of the pandemic but we
have not overcome it and now we have the
knock-on effects for example the food
crisis really coming at fast speed
um as a consequence of putin's war
in every aspect
we will not make it without the private
sector without the business sector we
need you and my experience in my time as
a president of the european commission
is that it is an excellent cooperation
with the business sector because the
business sector is taking on
responsibility i've seen it when we
started with the european green deal and
um now in in full-fledged you are at our
side coming with the innovation that is
needed to really have this green
transformation
we would never have thought that a war
also gives us a second good argument
really to accelerate the greens
transformation because of russia's
blackmailing us with fossil fuels
but the business sector is enormous
helpful
i am and i was impressed to see when we
unleashed
five packages of severe sanctions
how the business sector stood up
and took responsibility too
by
deciding to not only follow the
sanctions but
kind of self-sanctioning
their own
activities in russia
and leaving the country but also taking
care of their employees this was amazing
to see and is amazing to see
and now if i raise the topic of the food
crisis we will need all our combined
strength to manage that because there
are already millions of people
that are um very at at the very bottom
of poverty and do not know who had to
have a meal the next day but this will
be
much much getting much much worse over
the next month because
the ukraine
wheat and grain supply and the russian
rain supply which were the granaries of
the world isn't there anymore with all
the consequences for the poorest in the
world we'll need every helping hand and
you are always the masters of
precise tailored solutions and
innovations
so we can do the framework that eases it
for you or nudges you in the right
direction but the innovation the
solutions come from research and science
of course but also from the business
sector and therefore you are so
important
thank you on behalf of all the
participants
madam president for
you're so comprehensive
you